one of our favorite trips of the year to
the Undisputed heavyweight champion of
national parks no other Park comes close
to how big Wrangle Saint Elias is if
you're unfamiliar with it that's likely
because it's not exactly easy to reach
sitting on the edge of Alaska an
eight-hour drive from Anchorage
13.2 million pristine Acres with an
active volcano nine of the 16 highest
peaks in America and countless glaciers
Wrangle St Elias also contains the last
Community inside a national park about a
hundred full-time residents who are
convinced the best way to live is far
away from everyone else
foreign
it may not be as famous as other
attractions but Wrangle Saint Elias
National Park is larger than Yellowstone
Yosemite and Switzerland combined
there's a way to get an idea for the
scale the scope of this place
this park as massive as it is would be
completely underappreciated without
Aviation Austin Robel of wrangle
Mountain Air gave us the big picture
from above
if you guys look in the ice sometimes
you can see layers
that function basically the same as tree
rings and you can count those like tree
rings and see how many years worth of
ice you're looking at
for millions of years Wrangle St Elias
has been shaped by the competing forces
of volcanism and glaciation I mean how
many
how many volcanic and glacial activities
Fire and Ice
a hundred years ago the section of the
park we flew over was mined heavily but
no more the Alaska lands conservation
Act of 1980 protected
157 million acres in our 49 States
including Wrangle Saint Elias
right in the middle of that a throwback
to the days of the Kennicott mining
operation is still thriving we're in the
Park yeah we're in the geographic center
of the park
I mean it's it's as Central as you can
be in the park McCarthy is a
one-of-a-kind private Town accessible
only by plane a privately owned Bridge
or a footpath this was once Sin City
yeah like the quintessential Sin City I
mean it was moonshining gambling
prostitution today it's a little
different
Neil darrish is the town's largest
landowner one of the business people
serving a small year-round population of
locals and a growing number of seasonal
tourists when people go out into the
Wilderness and then they come here and
they're able to relax or they're able to
have a cold beer or whatever that's part
of the human condition today they want
to experience the unpredictable they
want to be surprised by an animal they
don't want to get eaten by a bear
so finding the way to help people enjoy
their Adventure that's really our role
in this area Adventure is not hard to
come by
it's wild walking through here it's it's
quite a spot isn't it yeah I mean
time forgotten Mike loso a geologist
with a National Park Service showed us
the restored buildings that once served
as the heart of mining town you know
what they ought to have here is a a
chase scene not to mention the site of
this elaborate video from John Denver's
1978 film Alaska the American child the
John Denver fan not many people I love
John do you nice good makes me like you
I'm a John Denver fan too huge John
Denver fan Wrangle Saint Elias is one of
the only places in the world you can
with reasonable efforts actually walk on
a glacier we go out this Trail a lot
we're gonna see Bears Maybe
wouldn't surprise me the five mile hike
takes you through some of the most
Majestic Beauty this land has to offer
along with interesting encounters on the
way
so there
staring at us
I mean he could come down and attack us
right now but I would say he's probably
not going to
no he's running away yeah that's what we
like him to do
we like to look at them and then watch
him leave
well that's cool that's cool yeah really
a little black bear yeah
it's not little yeah no he wasn't little
it's good that you brought the bear
spray
right you didn't he didn't bring the
bear spray
FYI
the glacier we travel to Tells A
Familiar story when I first came to this
Valley
for the very first time in 1990 coming
down this Trail you'd you'd get on the
ice just below where we're standing
right here and as you can see
the ice Edge is quite a distance away
we're going to walk it here in a moment
and you'll feel how far it is but that's
a measure in you know part of a human
lifetime of how far this Glacier is
retreated
the irregular shape of the surface is a
product of different areas melting at
different rates based on sun exposure
Rock debris covers some parts more than
others the basic idea and this is a good
place to point it out is
a very thin layer of dirt absorbs more
sunlight and melts faster but a thick
layer of dirt like this just a couple
centimeters thick
is enough to insulate the ice from the
Sun
and so it melts slower while cycles of
glaciers growing and receding over
hundreds of years are normal the rate of
melting over the last half century is
impossible to ignore how many feet down
it has it gone
at this particular location about 200
feet give or take and when you go down
to the the Terminus of the glacier just
a little ways Downstream of us there's a
huge Lake there now we call that a
pro-glacial lake and that Lake didn't
even exist when I first came here it
doesn't even have a name it's so new and
this summer my son and I are going to
build a sailboat and start sailing on
that Lake really that's the future
making the best of a new reality while
studying ways to preserve what's left
as our time on the Kennecott Glacier
Drew to a close another group of
adventurers were heading toward the ice
drawn by The Bucket List chance to visit
this Undisputed heavyweight champion of
national parks you know part of it is
those statistics you were just citing
they even sort of hide the truth of it
because 13.2 million Acres well that's
the park boundary but that boundary in
most directions is arbitrary it's more
Mountains more Wilderness more glaciers
North America's Mountain Kingdom that's
the term I prefer so you're saying the
park is actually bigger than it is which
is already the biggest the protected
lands
in this area are much bigger than just
Wrangle St Elias National Park and
preserve it's the core of a much bigger
protected landscape
how awesome is that super awesome
foreign
it is super awesome super super awesome
there's a super super there's a cool
reality show on McCarthy Alaska if you
want to check it out also the food there
in McCarthy is incredible really yeah we
did a dish on a place called The Potato
yeah remember that yes um and it was
just amazing uh people you know it's
only open three or four months a year
yeah you have to make it there but they
do a fantastic job I'm just remembering
that for Christmas I should have gotten
you bear spray I was just going to ask
how do you not bring Bears I know well I
thought he had brought
that's the thing you don't just assume
on I know yeah well I I would have got
you I mean you can't fly with it so you
need to get away there that's true